imagine a universe filled with an
infinite number of immortal people
living in Bliss they love it it is
awesome but each day one of them is
removed and sent away to a separate
Universe of suffering forever now
imagine a different Universe filled with
an infinite number of immortal people
who live in suffering in constant Agony
it's all they know but each day one of
them is removed and sent to live in
Bliss forever now in that first Universe
no matter how many days have passed no
matter how many people have been sent to
Eternal pain there will always be more
people who are happy than sad because
their initial population was infinite
it's unending however each and every one
of them knows that their day will come
that it will all come to an end in a
finite amount of time for some it might
be Googles of years but it's not going
to last forever but the Eternal pain
they're sent to will now conversely in
the other Universe there will always be
more people suffering but they will each
know that within a finite amount of time
they will escape which universe is
better